[Musica]
bello a tutti ragazzi un padre dove sono
video sono fa vigenti oggi siamo sul web
220 ragazzi e veloce da tagli bablok era
un range game ma che avevo giocato tipo
un anno fa una roba del genere l'ho
scoperto con gioia proprio che è uscito
anche il seguito e non potevo
assolutamente non farlo ragazze e
ragazzi e non su play perché vogliono
sono troppo voglioso di vedere che
diavolo l'obiettivo del gioco è quello
di non premere questo tasto il tasto
give up che in italiano significa
appunto arrenditi l'obiettivo del gioco
è quello di riuscire ad arrivare alla
fine senza aver premuto il tasto give up
c'è un casino quelli sono tutti i
livelli che devo fare sì ovviamente già
morto fantastico palla devo fare tutti
questi casi come faccia partito parole
per adesso ragazzi sono abbastanza
semplici però madonna che testaccio e
sono abbastanza se non molto
non lo so pensare più avanti che mi sta
sparando cose ma intanto i ragazzi
stanno già sto facendo lo so come stavo
scherzando vorrebbe iniziare a diventare
più incasinato ecco perfetto da
destinava come questo salgo posto pronto
e non ci arrivo mi sarò a ho capito
credo è ok se si no porca [ __ ] per ora
è ancora semplice per adesso uno rosso
pezzo ecco perche come non detto
stronzate è la madonna mica buttatevi
carrarmati già che ci siete morta la
donna che ho schivato questo schivato
porca [ __ ] pazzo oddio cosa scrivano
ragazze armi nati ho schivato le cose ma
porca [ __ ]
ho schivato le corse più impossibile le
cose più semplici ok ok ma bambini
piano piano sta ecco è diventato
difficile ragazzi si ok ma se vi state
chiedendo quando sarebbe iniziata la
parte difficile tana [ __ ] iniziato
adesso mi manca un secolo per finirlo
già non ce la faccio adesso fantastico
ok ok cazzo mezzo mezz'ora o cazz con
ricordi co e veloce e ve ne
qualcos'altro con locali ma ritorniamo
sul 9 16 che veramente assurdo reagan o
no sì sì sì sì sì bravissimo no perché
c'è la nonna che puzza dai dai
si si si calmi nero tasto gioco dovrebbe
portare all'esasperazione al tal punto
da cliccare il tasto give up ma io non
lo farò ragazzi ma cosa fosse va beh
forse lo faccia sì va beh devo essere
superman no kat
no no no puro mi sta scendendo l'anima
nell'inferno nonna mi sembrerebbe per il
culo o amica mafai cazzo come ho fatto a
mettere in pausa che non ho cliccato
niente ragazzi si è inserito la pausa da
sola ma va bene partenza partenza da dio
la finiamo non la finiamo ok ok piaceva
ma qualcuno veramente a parti scatti
qualcos'altro la prima volta l'ho fatto
chi va per ragazzi ho vinto subito ma
quanti ne dubito perché no no no l'ho
detto no per caso non so se l'ho detto è
vera è veramente assurda è una roba
atroce ma come faccio forse tutti i
regali che vuoi che dica adotterà un
bambino rock and roll
non so come cazzo fanno non voglio
neanche sapere che questo questo è
cambiato proprio completamente che è
stato questo non era difficile perfetto
se iniziano a essere tutti così mi sto
sono morto che iniziano essere tutti
così mi sta bene perché no ok ci ho
fatto perché c'è un il rinoceronte nella
missione arcula perché c'è un ritorno a
seriamente ma che adesso giorni eva non
muore so stronzo però che faccia
superare l'inno non l'ho capita sta cosa
si è fatta torna indietro armatore
indietro non indietro
si chiama pietro e torna indietro ci ho
messo mezz'ora per fare sta parte del
rinoceronte non vorrei dire però va bene
ok ok data da tyka mai 27 27 per cento
30 per cento dai maledizione ce la
possiamo fare se non è anche a metà
porca merda io ci provo lo stesso perché
sono in grado di farle col credo è
perfetto e smontando un pipistrello a
caso non l'ho capita questa prova beh se
faccio veloce lo evito subito no perché
sono stronzo ok questa sera il visto non
lo so non l'ho toccato perché non voglio
saperlo se si perfetto adesso adesso
hanno aggiunto della lava bellissimo
figlio di [ __ ] non ho visto che c'è
la cosa che cadeva mali ma li mortacci
sua chiedetemi che cosa ho fatto perché
non lo so neanche io ma ho rischiato di
morire in modo atroce perfetto chi
annego i pesci kakà mi sa che cacciari
di con gli occhi ma non più pistrella
l'ho vista bruttissima come faccio a
passare la lava ok madonna ti uccido ok
lo guarda stavo male il male di una
parte ci prova a farla abbastanza
velocemente si pipistrel io vi giuro li
faccio malneek strangolo tutti chi cazzo
di zu bud ok madonna cosa sto facendo le
che mai nella vita
come faccio come faccia passare
pipistrello merda due in uno madonna
cosa ho fatto come o come l'ho fatto non
lo so neanch'io perfetto gesù io come
faccio saltare un pipistrello una lama e
un [ __ ] rinoceronte tutti insieme
spiegato perché non lo capisco
adesso ci prova lo sapevo io lo sapevo
sì sì sì oddio oddio sto male carminati
un ragazzo un uomo donna stava accadendo
nella lava io sto uniti a sto venendo o
dio santo mi sto sentendo veramente
giuro mi sto sentendo ma come faccia un
essere umano a finire sta roba non ne ho
idea
io esco di qua faccio
lauryn rinoceronti cibi prodotti pronti
pronti così buzzi
no no no no no no ma perché da amica
cosa avevo fatto ma perché c'è un'arma
che spara supposte la sua arrivata al
piano 18 e mi sembra di giocare da da
anni no no se gli orfani l'origine vita
un hub a [ __ ] che ho vinto che non
riusciva anche il tuo in tutta la tua
vita ragazzi non so come ho fatto sia
mal round 19 al piano 19 al 20 al 50 per
cento di ostacoli concia posso più fare
veramente rendermi conto della
situazione di merda più no no no no come
faccio e vabbè si torniamo pure indietro
con rino soltanto cioè io già non riesco
a farlo normalmente mettiamoci pure la
cazzo di pistola ok lo so se coso
schivato rega non c'è mica è un ma certo
livello non lo vincerò mai nella vita
però ci prova uguale sappiate che mi ha
voluto bene
ricordatevelo questo madonna o donna no
[Musica]
non è così io io non so come ho fatto ad
arrivare lassù non di quella punta
troppa stata una base cosa ho aperto io
ti supplico fammelo finire una volta no
no no no
[Musica]
mio dio mio dio mezz'ora che non avete
capito non sapete quanto ci ho messo non
potete capirlo siamo al 20 faccio questo
cazzo di livello m me ne vado in
kazakistan novara che merda io giuro che
va futuro che vado a [ __ ] finire
questa in realtà ho chiuso bene levi il
video nel senso che riesco arrivare a
metà di belli tanto non ci riuscirò mai
nella vita però sono già contento di
essere arrivato fin qua ti prego io ti
giuro se riesci a farmelo fare ti giuro
non ti chiedo è scappato non ti chiedo
più un cazzo dalla vita ma ti prego ti
prego
e adesso come facesse una piena forma
piena forma piena forma sì sì sì sì sì
si può dire basta basta sono vado
siciliano e card ragazzi abbiamo fatto
un 20 livelli siamo a metà 50 per cento
non ne voglio più sentire senso come
questo sia semplice io lo stai sentendo
il mio potere paranormale piglio detroit
i ragazzi conclude episodio siamo
arrivati a più di metà 22 anche però va
bene non ce la posso più fare continuano
nel prossimo perché la prossimamente
sarà atroce non lo so già quindi ragazzi
spero che a vino vi sia piaciuto che le
scalate che siano servite a qualcosa
perché porta la merda non andrò più a
dormire non ho ancora premuto il tasto
give up e forse non lo farò neanche nel
prossimo episodio si spera però quindi
ragazzi servizio è piaciuto ma senza
sotto momento mi piace anche la pace di
facebook quadrani video trascrizione
solo se questi dischetti nocivi e uno
prossimo video delle ragazze